hi this is kim from khan academy today
we're learning more about the takings
clause of the fifth amendment in another
video we'll discuss the other clauses of
the fifth amendment those that deal with
self-incrimination and due process of
law but in this video we're
concentrating on just the last few words
of the fifth amendment which forbid the
government from taking private property
for public use without just compensation
to learn more about the takings clause i
sought out the help of two experts
richard epstein is the lawrence a tisch
professor of law and director of the
classical liberal institute at nyu law
he's also a senior fellow at the hoover
institution eduardo penalveir is the
alan r tesler professor and dean of
cornell law school so professor epstein
can you give us a little background just
what is the takings clause well there's
a rule in constitutional law that the
shorter the provision the more difficult
the interpretation and this is a very
short petition it says nor shall private
property be taken
for public use without just compensation
and the first thing to understand about
the clause is that it's in the passive
voice
so it doesn't tell you who's taking it
and early on since this was part of the
bill of rights it was said to apply only
to congress and not to the states
and then after the civil war through the
14th amendment it was said to apply to
the states so now it applies to both the
states and to the federal government uh
many constitutions don't have an
explicit property protection clause
but
there's a
fairly strong
norm around compensating owners of
private property when you
essentially commandeer their property
for public purposes and that and that
you know that seems to have been the
motivation it's you know i think the the
clearest reading of it is that it's a
provision of the constitution that makes
clear that when the federal government
takes your property or when the states
take your property for some public use
that they have to make you whole by
giving you just compensation private
property is a pretty comprehensive term
everybody understands that it means land
and the things you build on land they
also understand that it tends to cover
chattels that is things like books and
baseballs that you happen to own and
wild animals
but it's also is much broader than that
it covers all sorts of intangible rights
like patents copyrights trade secrets
these are very complicated and generally
speaking the government doesn't have any
obligation to create a patent but once
it gives you the patent it just can't
take it from you because the patent
after conferred is in fact now a
property right and then it also may or
may not cover other kinds of intangibles
like goodwill which is the value
associated with the business knowing
that your past customers may come back
to you in the future
on the motives of the framers for
including this talk about things like
the confiscation mostly of personal
property during the revolutionary war by
the british government um that that was
possibly a motivation to make clear that
if you know in future scenarios if the
government wanted to take your property
it would have to um it would have to
compensate you
you know i think most historians don't
think there was a real um problem being
addressed by this you know a problem of
uncompensated taking of property by by
colonial governments during during that
period
or by the by the state governments
during the articles of confederation the
framers wanted a system of what we call
limited government
and so what the takings cause
essentially says is yes we need your
land for a fort um and it's really very
important but if we're going to take it
and use it for a fort that's a public
use we're going to pay you compensation
for the fair market value of the land
before the fort was put on and this is
in order to make sure that you can't
pick and choose your victims and it's a
way of assuring government regularity
that's the first
second thing is more economic
less apparent at the time of the framing
but pretty apparent today
is if the government can take something
and not pay you compensation it's going
to overtake so your land is worth a
hundred thousand dollars as a farm uh
but if you're going to use it uh for a
ford it's only worth ten thousand
dollars if you don't have to pay the
hundred thousand dollars well you may
take it because you get ten thousand
dollars worth of gain but if you have to
pay the federal a fair market value of
the property interest taking you won't
do it so essentially what it does is it
makes sure or at least improves the odds
that when the government does take
property or does regulate it will in
fact improve overall social welfare so
you have a political function
dealing with singling out and you have
an economic function dealing with the
overall improvement of government
behavior from an economic point of view
okay so say i had a piece of land
and the government decided that they
wanted it for some purpose
what would be the legal process for the
government to go about acquiring my land
well
the the process for evident domain
really varies by state but typically
there's some notice that the government
gives you that it intends to take your
property that the government goes to
court and gets an order of condemnation
to take title to the property and then
often there's a requirement that the
government the government bargained with
you about the value of the property uh
it will tell you what it thinks the
value is the the fair market value is
the standard that we use for just
compensation that's the the value that a
willing buyer would pay to a willing
seller for the land
it doesn't include things like your
sentimental value or anything like that
so it's just the market value of the
property
uh there's some back and forth you know
through this required bargaining if the
government and the property owner can't
reach an agreement then the government
can go to court and get the court to
specify the value
of the property that will be paid in
compensation and then the payment is
made and the deed is transferred
and the government becomes the owner of
the property interesting so the
government has gone through this process
to try to acquire my land what if i'm a
real holdout and i just really don't
want the government to get my land what
happens then well you can litigate
various pieces of this and again it
depends a little bit on the state law so
some states put
more procedural hurdles in the way of
the government
other states
you know make it easier for the
government but
under the constitution they're really
only two ways you can resist
the taking of your property through
eminent domain one is by
arguing that the use that the government
plans to make of your property doesn't
count as a legitimate public use
because the clause says nor shall
private property be taken for public use
without just compensation and that
public use language has been interpreted
to be a limitation on the power of
eminent domain and then you can argue
the second thing you can argue is that
what the government is offering you in
terms of just compensation is not
adequate compensation
and you can litigate those through the
courts and that can slow the process
down quite a bit uh some states make it
easier for the government by saying well
the government can actually just take
title
uh while you litigate and um
um others make you go you know
you know allow you to stop the the
condemnation process and and litigate in
advance but
uh
there's there's often what's called a
quick take procedure which allows the
government to move more more quickly and
and put the litigation on the back end
the the public use if it's found if the
use is found not to be public you what
you win is yeah an actual prohibition on
the taking itself right you keep your
property if you win on the just
compensation side all you get is more
money they still take your property
so you mentioned public use what counts
as public use
well under the current law you know
any use that generates a
public benefit is really a public use
so the way the court has put it is
anything the government any
purpose the government can
pursue
through any other means
it can pursue through eminent domain so
if you know if the government wants to
create jobs or if the government wants
to beautify or if the government wants
to
remove blight all those things are
things that we think it's legitimate for
the government to try to do
if it can do those things
it can do them through the use of the
eminent domain power one thing that
strikes me as
interesting is just the fact that this
clause is in the fifth amendment among
things like double jeopardy or
self-incrimination so why do you think
the framers included this particular
clause here as opposed to elsewhere in
the bill of rights well that's a great
question to which there's no obvious
answer but the one clause that is pretty
close to it is the due process clause in
the fifth amendment says nor shall any
person be deprived of life liberty or
property without a due process of law so
if you start with the procedural stuff
somebody is going to say well how do we
know that the procedures aren't fair
and if it turns out that the government
uses a set of procedures
that don't give you adequate notice
you're always going to end up short on
the amount of compensation that you're
going to acquire
so bad procedures tend to lead to bad
outcomes which tend to lead to property
being taken at less than full market
value so what happens is therefore a
very close linkage between the
procedures used in under the due process
clause and the substantive protection
that you have undertaken any uh changes
in the interpretation of the takings
clause by the supreme court over time
well there's been a huge kind of switch
up and down and let me put it the
following way
in the beginning there wasn't much of
anything that was done with respect to
the takings clause the first federal
case to deal with it was called baron
against baltimore in 1833
or so and it just simply said that the
clause does not allow
for protection of mr barron against the
city of baltimore because it only binds
the federal government that doesn't bind
the state after the civil war
two things happen of a real distinction
the first thing is you start getting
comprehensive regulation of the
railroads and the rates they can charge
and then public utilities and the rates
that they can charge and then in 1921
there's a case called block v hirsch and
it's a very close five to four decision
but they sustain on the grounds that
it's a wartime a temporary two-year
statute that limits the rents that can
be charged in washington dc at the end
of the first world war one of the
biggest changes in the interpretation of
the taking squads was the extension of
the takings clause to govern situations
in which your property was not uh
appropriated by the government so what
we call the regulatory takings doctrine
which
started in in the
with the case of uh pennsylvania coal
versus mayhem in in the 1920s and and
then um has now become much more it was
sort of dormant for a while and become
much more active uh since the 1980s
uh
that's a doctrine that says if the
government regulates your use of
property uh excessively then
the courts can treat that in effect as a
confiscation of your property and
require the payment of just compensation
that was a pretty that's maybe the most
significant change in the interpretation
of the clause
you know in its history so there
continues to be controversy about the
public use doctrine modern commentators
especially libertarians want a very
narrowly drawn
account of public use and disagree with
the breadth of the doctrine as i
described it to you
and and so there's a lot of activism
around that there's been some state law
that's been enacted to try to uh raise
the floor there the federal definition
of public use is just the floor and
states can go beyond that and restrict
the power of eminent domain more
forcefully if they want to and many have
so we've learned that the takings clause
of the fifth amendment prevents both
federal and state governments from
taking private property for public use
without just compensation but there are
a lot of questions about what counts as
private property public use or just
compensation in recent years debate over
the takings clause has centered on
whether government regulations about how
a private individual can use land also
constitute a form of confiscation and
the extent of acceptable public uses for
which the government can seize property
to learn more about the fifth amendment
visit the national constitution center's
interactive constitution and khan
academy's resources on u.s government
and politics